merry christmas wishes for 2020
i like to keep things light-hearted at
christmas time
but we can't ignore that many of us have
had a difficult year
with illness uncertain employment
and isolation due to covert 19.
looking back at events of 2020
i felt extremely honoured to have been
chosen by my colleagues to continue to
serve as the chairman of rocha district
council
this is partly due to the cancellation
of the election
and the sad loss of my vice chairman
councillor terry cutmore
one of the greatest benefits of this
position is having the opportunity to
meet local residents or
and organizations that work so hard to
make a difference around our district
this year has been different and i've
missed meeting many local residents and
visiting local businesses
virtual meetings have become the norm
for most of us and i am no different
from a screen i have attended not only
council meetings but events in the
community such as a conscious demeanor
making ceremony
and havens light up a life event
it is humbling to see how olville
adapted to this new way of working
the highlight of 2020 has been the
community
response to the covid 19 pandemic the
rocha district community hub is a great
reminder of what the community can do
when we all work together we've had over
200 volunteers delivering food and
medicine
and offering reassurance to residents in
need
this hub is an asset to the community
and continues to help those in need
my own civic carol service was unable to
go ahead this year at the holy trinity
church in raleigh
i would like to give special thanks to
chairman's chaplain reverend david
oxtoby who has put together a virtual
service
which i will be taking part in and will
take place
on saturday the 19th of december at 7 pm
i also want to send thanks to the key
workers of workers who have worked
tirelessly throughout this difficult
year
to those who have worked in our schools
collected our waste and kept services
running
i will be joining in with a bell ringing
from my doorstep at 6 00 pm on christmas
eve to show my thanks
over the next six months of my
chairmanship i look forward to seeing
more of our residents and businesses
and to celebrating the successes to come
in a new year
i will be thrilled to be present to
support you and join in with celebrating
your achievements
so if you would like to invite me to
share an event with you please contact
the civic officer
by email at civic.officer
rochford.gov dot uk or visit the
chairman's page on the rocha district
council website
to download an engagement form
stay safe this christmas while indulging
in your minch pies
please stick to the rules in place while
you enjoy spending time with loved ones
i'll be seeing my mother for the first
time in many months
which i'm very much looking forward to i
wish you all a merry christmas and best
wishes for a happy and safe 2021.